hello everybody markiplier here with
markiplier x' Monday male mayhem madness
menagerie of monsters in male I'm gonna
come up with a new name every time so
guy I can't nail down any one thing so
anyway I got my giant pile of mail here
they were kind enough to give me a cart
there's actually just a little bit more
than there was last time it may not look
like it but there actually is more off
to the side in terms of letters in terms
of boxes it's probably roughly the same
and to save time I have already cut open
all of them I haven't looked in any of
them now mind you I haven't looked in
any of them I just cut them up and I
have to talk louder because I'm going to
be walking over there a lot and you're
not gonna be able to hear me I was one
of the complaints before as I was moving
away from the camera you couldn't hear
me so here we go
Wow well I guess I didn't talk much on
the way both first box it's already cut
open everything just so I can I could
actually open it up and ooh ooh it's a
little dingy mustaches it's an envelope
huh oh god I still can't open anything
okay it's got my face on the cover so
that's adorable let's see it's the
thoughtfulness of people like you that
makes the world's so bright I have been
struggling with depression you're a very
nice man you care very deeply about your
fans and that makes me very happy seeing
your videos makes me smile and laugh you
brightened my day and I'm very thankful
for that
thank you so much Taylor so thank you
and oh it's a box of Jesus I was
confused cuz I looked at this and I was
like what is this oh it's Jesus sounds
like it might have gotten crushed in
delivery a bit but either way thank you
so much for the cheese's I'll add that
to my collection I've got about 50 boxes
now that I don't know what to do with
besides eat okay next what do we got
here a newspaper oh wait there's more
newspaper alright hang on as you can see
I'm not even sitting down because it
would take wha
uh-oh that was creepy oh my god I just
opened it and looked down and saw this
ah ha that's nightmare fuel right there
that's that is my god I'm gonna throw
that away
no I'm just kidding that's that's really
cool but also really scary to see okay
all right
anything else in there don't see
anything soon that's it okay I'm gonna
assume that's it
next yeah I'll just open them down here
it's much easier oh ah it's a portal
cube plushie I love this I can't have it
with my weird my I don't know where it
is okay I my portal perd is not here my
portal turret is not here I don't know
where it went
but otherwise I would stick it with this
cuz this is really cool I like that
thank you thank you so much there's a
note to go with it
no there's not cuz it's completely blank
huh see ya here's a note a little bit of
exercise really did me in huh what the
oh look at this they said it was a
private gift no need to YouTube it but
look at that it's a little bottle of
stars what's in the stars What's in
these stars cocaine I think cocaine
stars alright there's that whoa
it's an aperture science t-shirt that's
so cool thank you so much and I doesn't
have a sizing but I'm sure it'll fit so
thank you so much
there's also Pocky and more portal
there's portal ice cubes yeah yeah it's
the best Christmas ever
yeah wait I love this oh that's so
oh I like ice cubes I got I used the
brain ones when I was recording drunk
minecraft last night this is no girl
okay there's a lot of stuff in this box
and we got that is so geeky it's it's a
it's a um no not uh beaker uh it's a
graduated beaker but um I forget the
name besides beaker but it's also a mug
that's so cool
it reminds me of that episode Austin
power or that part of Austin Powers
where they tried to get never mind I'm
not even gonna talk about that alright
so thank you so much there's also some
other stuff there bird emergency stuff
and a label that's it thank you so much
a lot of stuff ah but there's also Pocky
t-shirt newspapers creepy ass statue
over there next this one I couldn't open
all the way cuz there was some nice
wrapping at London everyone to see that
and that cool okay going away rip rip
rip oh oh there's another box in here uh
uh as prepared as I want to be I'm never
prepared all the way yeah there we go
alright put that there alright let's see
there's a note a piece of paper poof
poof okay is there anything in here oh
here we go
it's um it's a poof mousepad oh cool
that's actually pretty cool I'm actually
um what I'm gonna do and I want you guys
to know about this um for the charity
livestream I'm gonna take some of these
things and I'm gonna give it away to
donate it so if you donate more than $5
you'll be entered in to win some of
these cool prizes and I'm actually going
to include some games in there if you
guys send me games and stuff if you want
to send stuff to give away on a charity
livestream you're more than welcome
I'll get a big pile going you know
there'll be tons of prizes to win so
lots of shipping costs but I don't
really care about that so thank you guys
I might give that away it doesn't mean
that I'm I'm like I don't like your gift
I'm gonna give it away no I'm just
saying like I if I don't have an
immediate use word because I already
have a nice gaming mouse mat and I
really like the present but someone else
one of my fans would love that so that's
just a reason why I think I could give
that away so thank you if you don't want
me to give it away please explicitly say
so whoo it's a sweatshirt from Alaska
whoa I've never had a sweatshirt about
the whole state of Alaska before so
that's pretty cool - medium - I mean
winners almost over so that's actually
like 75 degrees outside so don't know if
I have a chance to use this but that's
still really cool could be a giveaway
it's anyone one in Alaska sweatshirt I
bet you do who wouldn't file next what
do we got big box huh ah adorable dad
cool all right there's a letter here I
just want to tell you how much I love
your videos especially when you play a
scary game that freaks you out like if
we've never seen before
Kuro Oni is the one that springs to mind
I first found out about you when you did
that minecraft collab with yamimash and
arrow in the knee I heard your voice and
heard how funny you were and had to
subscribe I haven't regretted doing so I
love your videos and so does my little
boy I especially like your my little
pony mod of SCP containment breach as
well as your other scary indie games but
my favorite series has to be drunk
minecraft thank you I love drunk
minecraft anyway I'm starting to ramble
other than your treats I have given you
reduced fat cheese it because you're
saying how you're gonna make you fat and
a Rainbow Dash figure because we all
know you love her the most
insert troll face here much non homo
love your brony fan in houston jeremy
binoy well yeah I've now have two more
boxes of cheez-its to add to the
election I'm not gonna pull those out
and then Oh zebra cakes those are
definitely gonna give me fat in a
Rainbow Dash My Little Pony I'm
definitely gonna give those away
hahahaha oh it's gonna be a non burn iam
gonna win them and they're gonna be a
what god I'm just kidding I'm not play
around with all the brothers I have
nothing Esperanza really I don't just
that I am NOT one-one I am NOT one and
I'm never gonna be one so next this one
I'm actually looking forward to because
this one is from the UK I believe either
way somewhere overseas Royal Mail so I'm
just assuming it's from the UK oh it's a
giant Easter egg but though what I was
doing as there's like so whole it looked
like a hole in it at first but that's
just a place for Krispies or whatever
and they would saying Britain you some
nice crisps no those are potato chips
you know crunchy things like you Britons
would say what would you British say
thank you for that whatever an angel
delight is whip up with fresh milk what
is good what is this love hearts well we
have those in America so that's not
really that's not really that
extraordinary but what is all this
British candy this is all ridiculousness
I can't even understand any of this
there's also a card I'm actually taking
longer than I thought I was per box so
Easter there's a special kind of
loveliness that only comes spring blah
blah blah you three keep up the great
work with your videos and thank you for
the many hours of laughter I know you
may not have the time to write me back
but if you could it would make my day I
do not but here we go is this good
enough from England
Rebecca Purdy thank you into the pile
yeah this is actually a two-parter
because it's got an envelope as well as
a box the envelope contains oh wow
I can't read all that but there's fan
art Oh Slendy man I remember seeing that
on deviantART slender carnival I have
some wicked legs in this one look at my
god look at me man I've been biking or
some no no no no no no no no no go thank
you so much for that let's see what's in
the box
ah look at that
look at that Adso it's a perk ature
whatever you you know it's the I don't
want Pokemon but uh that's one of those
them are uh it's a yellow one um a
number or a pokey or uh la plana platypi
that's what it is
got it thank you so much for the platypi
love that um oh my god he's gigantic
boxes there's jelly bean spilling out
all over the box but there's cookies ha
ha ha
love me some cookies they look like
chocolate chip or are those raisins I
want to hear those raisin cookies no
they're chocolate chip ok we're good and
lots of Easter candy a solid white
chocolate bunny with ha oh this is where
your jelly beans were attached I think
oh they fell out another ever and
there's a bunch of other candy so thank
you so much for that happy Easter and
whatnot
I actually during Easter I was at my
stepmoms and I was visiting her and
there was this little kid there he
couldn't have been too but he was
stealing for my Easter Bacchus basket so
I went over my hi that's my candy not
mine and he ran away screaming like oh
no and I ran after him like cuz he still
had my candy in my hand so I ran up to
him like that's my candy I was like
crawling like this on the ground my
candy and he cry like a baby
huijun horn yo got my candy back though
yeah just a little story time with
markiplier what do we got here whoa we
got a game
Mass Effect 3 I've already played it so
that's definitely wait yep Mass Effect 3
is in there so that's definitely one for
the giveaway I mean I've already played
it played all the DLC well not all of it
just the Citadel I like the Citadel
didn't like the ending blah blah blah
same thing though and then there's a
flashlight and batteries here I guess
what I guess that could be useful that's
a useful thing so thank you so much for
that oh it's a combo flashlight laser
pointer look there's a little laser
thing and a warning for a laser on it
that's so cool thank you so much for
that alright so that's a game for the
giveaways and a box for the pile Wow how
come the finger the other day it hurts
real bad mmm
I didn't cut it opening those though so
you don't need to feel bad about that
all right something from Amazon trying
to hurry along here what is this what
what what is what is this why do I have
to open everything twice ridiculousness
man people just give me so much crap I
have to open it why don't I have a guy
for this god I'm a celebrity ah what is
this gift wrapped it's Amazon gift wrap
mmm it's game shaped so I'm going to
assume that it's a game what do we got
oh my god I have to open this three
times are you kidding me
God these gifts people shower me with I
can't believe that I have to open these
oh man what a pain
God wish oh man I'm dying here I'm dying
there we go finally killing me who it is
a game oh wow shocked infinite I just
finished this it's the mother end I'm
not gonna talk about but oh my god
whoever gets this in the giveaway you
are so damn lucky it is amazing and it's
the PC version to the superior master
race version of the game which is click
I spit on my camera
I spit on my camera sorry sorry about
that dog all right there we go I think I
got it yeah pretty much guy but whoa
someone gonna get this ha ha or I'll
test dalam on me BAE okay thank you so
much wait
hint hint if you don't want it or / feel
free to give it away to a lucky fan I
already have the game and love it warmly
Kim so tell Martin go and get it
someone's gonna get it I'm not
responsible for anyone's blown minds or
anything blown on anyone not my
responsibility
see readme for first I promise I'm short
well you really don't need to tell about
talk about your height markiplier that's
not short we want world these issues I
guess in terms re I just want to say
thanks for so much for being you as
scared as I am I usually while watching
I am usually while watching you play
games always you always make me laugh I
think once in a lifetime you meet a
person who has the ability to change the
world and even though I've never met you
there is no doubt in my mind that you
are the gold hearted individual who can
really make a difference a few small
gestures and a couple good laughs makes
a difference in someone's life most
people are only able to do that a few
times in their life but you've done it
every time you've made a video or
supported someone you're making a
difference Worth wild and I'm so glad
I'm a fan of yours keeping you as long
as you do someone's day will be mate
you're amazing
Morgan Clark a fan from central New York
the note was a little long I didn't
break the promise I'm only 5 - ah ha ha
ha ha ha ha I love when things come
together like that so thank you
now what's in here it's a CD of
something is it porn Oh me and I hope I
really don't hump it I can't show it on
cameras but it is oh gosh you gotta open
it
Oh like quadruple wrapped in but this is
not necessary it's a CD it'll hold up oh
god it's gonna be more damaged by me
opening it okay it's a CD of
mysteriousness so someone's gonna get it
and they're gonna be totally surprised
no I'm gonna I'll open that later so
thank you edify scrap crap in the pile
okay next let's see quick quick quick
quick quick quick quick quick
it's more talky I ate these I ate two
before I liked them
can someone send me something other than
the Fuego cuz if way go we're good but
little spicy so thank you when there's a
note too I'll give you the short version
dear mark you're awesome
Bryan Kellerman Keller Mayer okay you're
extremely hilarious and fun to watch it
can't believe the amount of dedication
you put in your hand it's astounding if
you haven't got my email the bag is the
bag of takis when I went to buy them for
you my my high school people asked if
they could have some I told them I was
mailing to someone so they can try them
I said that is a waste and I should just
eat them write that in there I wanted to
eat them but instead I just bought a
second bag for myself okay this rambling
about takis but thank you that was like
a long story that I did not need to know
like I went to buy and then my friends
told you not to told me to eat him then
their but they said they wanted some and
I said I would mail you to someone but
then they went I like I just bought
another bag for myself so you can have
this one I ate this with my friends
thanks okay I'm making fun of people
sending me stuff I really shouldn't do
that I'm gonna do it anyway you got a
shirt ooh what is this it's a creeper
jerk it's a it's the creeper Anatomy
shirt I saw this I wanted this but I'm
gonna have to give it away ah okay
someone else can have it enjoy it so
thank you so much does this is a cool
price there's gotta be a lot cool prizes
so you better show up and donate you're
better to all time or research okay
thank you so much who was that from
Newbury Comics yes okay I don't know you
got a white tin Smashbox whatever that
means with the bomb
there is a duct-tape art it's a
duct-tape wallet
it's a duct-tape wallet with a fake fake
money in it the 44 dollar bill oh I
remember this it looks so real but the
wall is cool my friends used to make
duct tape walls before and there they're
actually kind of hard to do so thank you
hmm what am I gonna do with 44 whole
fake dollars oh okay
yeah something else here um what's up
just want to say I love you no homo
maximum homo
I hate nohomo nohomo was a homophobic
thing there man
a little Matt loss sorry spelling okay
thank you thank you so much and all
right thank you you're the bomb know
that Cindy goes thing all right well we
got I'm starting to sweat I'm moving
around more than I thought I wasn't
it's bronies and what do you know it's
Rudy and two which makes it plural
bronies okay and then there's this red
this red crap that got everywhere cuz
one of my boxes spilled last time and it
dumped it everywhere really annoying but
thank you thank you for the brownies
you're awesome you're the bomb don't
tell em to go hmm Oh God peanuts
everywhere packing peanuts what is this
ha ha ha yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay all right that's it over
there
nothing messing around probably not the
important thing
Oh screamer ice cube trays yes I'm gonna
collect so many ice cube trays this is
amazing
look at it as a screener it's a very
important piece of art if you don't know
what this agreement is come on learn
some culture okay who else is in here
there's more stuff Oh
the skull shot glass oh god yes I'm
actually sweating right now and I'm
actually honest-to-goodness sweating
right now I have to take this shirt off
no don't thank you and there's actually
something else in here behind all the
pins ha ha ha ha
it's shot glass ice cube tray what what
that's it's shot glass ice cube tray it
shot glasses made of ice that's like the
greatest thing ever
that's so cool okay all right nothing
I'm gonna calm down cuz I'm losing it
I'm losing it over these yeah I'm losing
I'm gonna have to give one of those away
so it's probably gonna be the shot glass
no I gotta keep that no it's gonna I'm
gonna give away the shot glass glass ice
tray that is so good all right we're
actually making good time
Fuli dog alright there's some big in
here we've got does that what is that
the bond well he's gonna be a bomb
someday what is gonna be the bomb
someday what the whoa what whoa I saw I
ripped this on the way Horrell the
handwriting name is Dewayne 16 year old
lalalala shocked to death man dark times
so thank you and I don't know what this
is not much describing what this is but
look look at that it's it's um it's a
replica of dead space plasma cutter I
think that is like it lights up - would
you take that Necromorph bastards take
yeah I'm going a black you
my dad my cutter this is so cool uh uh I
got these are like the coolest toys and
there's more stuff here so only me
there's more stuff in here
there's like so oh no way it's it's oh
my god that's so cool it's a poker set
with like it's a mini poker set and dice
but they're all they're all themed like
they're there these are nuke dice
they're nuke dice I'm guessing the nuke
is one that's so cool and they're nuke
poker chips oh man it's just like a
fallout thing I don't know but either
way that's really cool these are some of
the coolest things and there's a game
here yeah what's Fallout it's Fallout
New Vegas I have never played New Vegas
I felt I played fallout 3 but not New
Vegas so I might give that a try or give
it away I'm not sure this is definitely
staying with me nobody's getting this
this is mine and it's so cool it's too
cool ha ha ha ha there's actually more
stuff here too but I'll look in that
later that's a lot of little stuff I'll
take care of it at some point down the
road just not right now ok all right
that goes over there which goes over and
this goes in the game pile Oh actually
this goes in the game pile too and this
stays close with me so thank you so much
that's really cool all right we're out
of boxes we're into envelopes now so
what could arrive it's always a surprise
Oh candy candy thank you from Finland
someone something candy from Finland oh
there's an envelope - wait a la la la
here's some from Finland ja hello Marc
my name is Alona and I'm from Finland
the first video I watched from you as
drunk minecraft and i have been watching
more of your videos ever since I
especially love watching you play and eg
accustomed stories hint hint your videos
always put a smile on my face and make
me laugh on that
days and I thank you for that I admire
you too the way you make use of your
fame to have others who need you're an
amazing person and I hope you know it
keep on doing what you do and I hope
these later puts a smile on your face as
always smile on my face
PS I hope you like to do to dong and
candy I think you and all congratulating
for 200,000 love on ikinema mu it's
literally the name I can mine mo sorry
for insulting your Finnish heritage with
my horrible accent hahahaha thank you
thank you okay alright Oh sweating
sweating up a storm all right what do we
got it looks like shot glass maybe oh my
god that's impossible to unwrap but
there's moustaches on it you can see a
moustache saw shot glass it's literally
like completely wrapped so I'll open
that later and there's also a note here
and oh my goodness I'm literally
sweating can you see the sweat on the
side of my face is how out shape I am
I'm completely out of shape tis
ridiculous let's see oh my god never
subscribe to a YouTube channel ever
before until I ran into your one of your
videos a few months ago I wasn't even
much into horror games and that barely
heard of slender but I watched your
videos and couldn't stop laughing I
ended up watching for five or six hours
of other videos you posted right after
so thank you so much I wish I could make
my own indie horror game for you to
believe uh sadly that area's not my
expertise however I did include a gift
for you thanks for all the laughs and
thrills may it bring you as much joy as
you have to all the fans I hope you
might open this in the fan mail episode
so I continue reaction to the often gift
you said you love getting shot glasses
you wrapped it up too tight too tight I
can't open it it's too much there's too
much there we go oh it's a bunch of
different mustaches and our names you're
all just eating because I can't grow one
okay thank you
hey yo much okay ah let's take a little
break okay break over Oh
there's still a lot of stuff to get
through mostly letters now oh look at it
banner hey thank you so much I'd read
this at school you drew it that Schewel
what ah yeah and a little Lego figure
look at that and you say you wanted to
be a scientist whoa your spelling is way
off bread man come and get it together
whoa
mop up my sweat with one of these
letters just huge tears streaming down
my face okay what do we got here
okay please read letter first then open
that feels like a game type thing oh my
god where's my letter opener Shing swing
got it all right oh this is a long one
I'm writing to you because I'm a big fan
and you finally have a peel box before
you open the enclosed item I want to say
a few things first of all when washing
your since yeah me wash death of the
dream plays Lommy Yami since moment I
start seeing more more videos I have one
of two hundred thousand subscribers it
is amazing you finally with two hundred
thousand I am Allah youtuber myself I
only have fifty but I am mainly a blip
let's see I'd like you to watch some of
my videos which are mostly movie reviews
and though I haven't posted in any in a
long time I'm working on more here's the
address
I'll please check it out I will try
secondly wondering collaborate on let's
play a movie review or something just
thought that it might be fun maybe I
could even do a drunk minecraft view
okay now it's time for the big reveal
DVD I made of the Slenderman it's a DD
DB D of Slenderman yes and you made your
own custom title screen okay thank you
and I'm not doing collabs with other
people at this moment sorry I'm really
just focusing on my own stuff it's time
sorry okay anyway I'll try to check out
your video or your your channel in a
while let's see so this is a two-disc
special edition of the Slenderman which
is he said it was based off of the movie
that someone else made and it's a
two-disc and he made his own custom
stuff so this could potentially be a
pretty good giveaway I've never seen it
myself so I may watch it and then give
it away so thank you so much for that
and like thank you you guys have been
doing an incredible job okay this goes
here in the pile all right more MORE
well this isn't fan mail
that's not fan mail wait a minute I
didn't know that's that's um not that
isn't that something else okay never
mind them yep
look oh it's another man I've been
getting a lot of games
let's end war isn't that the one you
play with like a microphone you're
supposed ha ha ha
the difference is uncanny okay so okay
yo what up mark I know that you have a
lot of things to open so this will be
short here's a game for you to give away
could you please give me a my friend a
shout-out the beastly player XP and that
guy Cosmo alright I will probably give
that away I've never played before but
I've heard it decently good so someone
will probably get fun out of this so
another game for the bottom man I've got
all surprising amount of games here like
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 games to give away oh
man that's really cool thank you alright
Oh get in there get in there get in
there guys I I don't want these to be
hour long videos just so you know what
we got here
ah right get that out of here get dad
out I'm more mature than that you're not
gonna be swayed by your your jokes okay
someone sent me what what what
someone sent me something wrapped in a
mountain Dew box a Diet Mountain Dew box
oh ha ha look at that little e look at
that that's cool huh and a no no no
splendor thing though thank you
but couldn't you have just sent it in
this the mailer okay whatever you do
your thing I'll I'll keep this over here
with the other ones now I've got I got I
tried to keep some things around so now
I've got these and I think there was
another one I just don't know where it
is right now so thank you all right what
yes warden she just Marilyn yes yeah
yeah stop ripping open all right there
we go ha ha you people are killing I'm
I'm an old man I'm old and out of shape
you're killing me all right what did
little piggy
Oinky Oinky okay okay okay and Oh to
Yoshi
Oh lugar da doo boo doo Yoshi oh that's
adorable and there's a note that is
right here all right up yep
oh my god dama I'm happy to stumble upon
your chant while searching for this one
or elementary I'm just thunder
elementals on you it was the newest
slender map at the time that was I
believe a year ago
not quite less than a year ago and I've
been subscribed since after finding your
slender videos unbelievable
of course anyway I always love watching
videos because I love seeing your
reactions to scary stuff you always make
me smile in every video you do keep
doing what you're doing and stay awesome
sincerely Megan sorry about the
packaging I hope it wasn't too much
trouble in opening ah alright there's
something else in here too what is this
oh look at that it's a little charm
bracelet with a palm tree well isn't
that nice
then they're nice no no no no no almost
done almost there oh I didn't even open
this one oh yes I did okay what do we
got what do we got oh yeah okay alright
SimCity 3000 this is this is such was
probably my favorite SimCity game that I
played sin 33000 was one of the coolest
and I actually just saw a reddit post
recently about this guy that made the
optimal SimCity City it was so horrific
Lee post futuristic apocalyptic scenario
there was like no hospitals no fire
station but it had maximum people and
enough police stations to keep everyone
in check and it had 6 million population
and no crime like no like ever would
like it was amazing what he did but this
is like one of the best SimCity games
there is much better than no one but
anything is okay so this someone will
love this whoever gets that you are a
lucky look person okay there was
something else in here too a letter oh
my goodness it's a lot of letters oh
it's good Tran our - my name is Sean I
have heavily enjoy your videos 15 and
don't have a very good home life
whenever I'm feeling sad I turn to your
videos and they always make me laugh
your kindness often surprises me I'm a
recent addition to the fan base and I
had only recently heard of your
donations to popular charities it makes
me happy that there is someone who uses
his fame and subscriber base for
something that it good unlike others I
really like your sense of style of humor
and your amazing voice which rivals
Morgan Freeman thank you
I need a friend that was a longest night
of his life
oh my balls says holy balls screaming oh
my god that yeah okay
oh I'll read this later it looks like a
story how I will try to read that at
some other point so thank you so much
all right
just a few more now almost done what do
we got we got Gibbs Kershaw made in USC
doesn't sound very USA doesn't sound
murica oh it's a knife I'm pretty sure
you weren't allowed to smell me this but
that is cool Wow it's a little knife I
could use this to splice my enemies and
cut my fingers again cool huh
it says my name on it ah yes what dot
dot looks sharp yeah that looks very
sharp I will stab my enemies and
flenderman in the balls with visnur I
don't know I'm talking in that strange
accent but um where's the UH where's the
fold trigger where's the fold button how
do I close this I'm mark I don't
understand this
where's the club where's the thing to
close it all right I'll just leave it
open for now and figure that out later
okay and that's a Mario it's me Mario
Oh that'll go great with my Yoshi which
is right here yes I do keep them nearby
- are you going to boingy boingy boingy
and another you keep putting your buggy
buggy i sell it over they don't go
buying you boy me I know that I play
these games there's like my platypi over
here I know I know the salad that these
animals make and they're very tasty god
I love the platypi hmm
go ones all eased out later thank you
and we just got
this big one here that I'm actually
gonna it's the last one that I'm gonna
open I'm gonna use this knife to open it
there's some art in here but I just got
to be careful this is a sharp knife good
knife he's like crazy sharp Juve I hope
it doesn't snap back on my fingers cuz
I'm I've lost enough blood for the week
ah what is this dive under oh I don't
need to wonder anymore because I'm
looking at it yeah
once again it's impossible to open for
an empire so there we go actually that
was pretty easy to move this one is
elegantly designed because it just pulls
off it just pulls off and you can see
what it is
cool huh it'll haunt my dreams on my
wall that's really cool that's really
well done nice job there hombre thank
you so much it looks great
thank you guys from Jordan Rick's so
that will just about do it for today's
mail bash wait hang on those another one
here that said please read on camera so
I forgot about this let me read it on
camera since you've decided to bag so
much gah oh um I think your Thin Mints
got a little uh you weren't supposed to
mail that and one of these are in wanted
in one of these the thank you all right
cool and good lordy this looks like an
essay uh I'm regret opening this one I
regret it I'm not gonna listen to anyone
anymore my name is Jacob
I'm 12 I subscribe sometime in October
my sister introduced me to you you make
me happy when I am sad my dog and cat
both got hit and died not six months
apart I gotten bullied at school a lot I
try
about my size weight and oh the thing I
don't know about other than but all the
anger just flows out of my body can't
run don't look or it takes you no no I'm
just this is I'm sorry that you're
believe it thank you so much Jacob that
I don't mean to make fun when people
give me free stuff so thank you guys
really so much I'm going to spend a lot
of the rest of the day
opening the letters all the letters are
over there in a pile and there are so
many of them but I'm gonna open all of
them and read them for now this is the
end so thank you all so much for
watching for another Monday male
markiplier madness man and read love
mail mmm mmm mmm huh so thank you again
everybody in like seriously thank you
for sending all this stuff I'm gonna
give away a lot of this on the charity
livestream there's tons of prizes
there's literally dozens of stuff that I
could give away so thank you all so much
for giving me this stuff I don't deserve
it
except for this I totally deserve this
this is so cool it's so cool I died I
earned this
I earn this I I earn this I did I just
did I I am I am I'm I I am great that's
what I'm trying to say and this proves
it so thank you all so much for watching
thank you for everything you've done I'm
gonna try to keep these in some sort of
playlist or something but anyway thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye